hay muchas formas de representar una
ecuación lineal así que digamos por
ejemplo que tenemos la ecuación que es
igual a 2 x + 3 muy bien tenemos esta
ecuación y en realidad hay una infinidad
de formas de representar esta misma
ecuación verdad por ejemplo podríamos
pasar este 2x del lado izquierdo verdad
restamos 2x de ambos lados y obtenemos
menos 2x más igual a 3 esta es otra
forma válida de representar la misma
ecuación verdad o bien también podríamos
hacer algo de este estilo de menos 5 es
igual a 2
bueno quizás debería poner antes del
paréntesis 2 por x menos 1 verdad
entonces si te das cuenta que está un
llegue aquí está el 2x aquí está este
menos 5 que pasa del lado derecho como
más 5 y aquí hay un 2 x menos 1 que
sería menos 2 y entonces 5 menos dos nos
da este 3 verdad entonces estás
tres formas distintas de representar
exactamente la misma ecuación y todas
son equivalentes se puede llegar a
cualquiera de ellas utilizando
operaciones algebraicas muy bien lo que
vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
enfocarnos principalmente en esta
ecuación muy bien en esta forma de
representar la y la verdad es que es muy
útil digo también también estas otras
dos son muy útiles pero la primera es
muy útil en particular muy bien
y de hecho esta forma de representarlo
tiene un nombre y es la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen aunque esta es la
forma pendiente ordenada ordenada al
origen y ahorita veremos exactamente a
qué se refiere todo esto pero digamos
primero que vamos a graficar lo muy bien
vamos a tratar de graficar esta ecuación
entonces vamos a poner nuestro valor x
nuestro valor y hagamos una tablita con
distintos valores para ver qué puntos
representan a esta línea y por ejemplo
podríamos empezar con tomando el valor x
igual a 0 verdad y si x vale 0 entonces
este término ya no pinta ya no es
necesario y tenemos que ya vale 3 muy
bien entonces ese sería nuestro primer
punto vamos a tratar de graficar lo
y vamos a hacer unas líneas
tenemos el 1er
quizás así está bien y pongamos otro eje
ahí está muy bien no sé vamos a hacer
algunas marcas digamos este es el 1
el 2 este sería el 3
digamos que ponemos una marca aquí que
sería el 1 aquí estaría el 2 aquí
estaría el 3
ok quizás necesitemos más 4
muy bien y pues aquí tendríamos el -1 y
aquí estaría también el -1 muy bien
entonces ahí tenemos nuestros ejes ok y
este primer punto simplemente lo ponemos
aquí verdad este es el primer punto que
hemos encontrado así que si nos fijamos
muy bien estamos precisamente sobre el
eje y eso nos dice que ese punto es la
ordenada al origen verdad y si vemos
esta ecuación podemos distinguir aquí un
3 aquí podemos distinguir el 3
así que ya podrás darte una idea de por
qué a esta forma de representar las
ecuaciones lineales se le conoce como la
forma pendiente ordenada al origen
porque esta constante representa la
ordenada o la altura digamos que diste
el punto del origen verdad es la
ordenada al origen y entonces también
podrías estar pensando bueno entonces
quiere decir que en algún lugar se
encuentra ahí escondida la pendiente y
tienes toda la razón vamos a ir viendo
cómo es que obtenemos esto digamos ahora
que tomamos una equis igual a 1 es decir
estamos pensando en un cambio de x igual
a más 1 verdad quizás debería hacerlo un
poco más grande
un poco más grande el cambio en x es
igual a más 1 verdad
recordemos que este triangulito este
triangulito es la letra griega delta y
que significa cambio verdad literalmente
significa cambio entonces si x vale 1
cuanto vale ya bueno tendríamos 2 x 1
que es 2 + 3 eso nos da 5 verdad
entonces si calculamos cuál fue el
cambio en el cambio en que es 2 verdad 2
positivos pasamos de 3 a 5 y eso nos da
un cambio de 2 positivos muy bien qué
pasa si por ejemplo tomamos otro cambio
de x igual a más 1 entonces tendríamos x
igualados cuánto valdría y bueno
tendríamos 2 por 2 son 4 3 son 7 verdad
entonces nuevamente tuvimos un cambio de
iu igual a más 2 muy bien entonces en
realidad podríamos calcular la pendiente
fácilmente como hemos visto en otros
vídeos simplemente hay que dividir
el cambio en que sería el cambio
dividido entre el cambio en x en este
caso el cambio siempre es 2 y el cambio
en x hicimos que fuera 1 lo cual nos da
un valor exacto de 2 verdad 2 es el
valor de nuestra pendiente y de hecho
podríamos entonces graficar lo por
ejemplo si tenemos el punto 15 verdad
más o menos corresponde a este punto
verdad y podríamos ya con estos dos
puntos trazar la línea que corresponde
a ésta a la gráfica de esta ecuación
lineal verdad sería algo como
de este estilo vamos a intentarlo
más o menos verdad que vamos a extender
esta línea todo lo que podamos ahí
tenemos nuestra recta verdad entonces
esta línea corresponde a la gráfica de
ye igual a 2 x + 3 verdad entonces lo
que podemos observar es que cada vez que
nos movamos uno a la derecha verdad que
es lo que nos dice nuestro cambio en x
que vale 1 vamos a tener un cambio
de 2 verdad lo mismo si nos movemos 1
hacia la derecha verdad más o menos
tendremos otros 2 hacia arriba o bien
podríamos movernos hacia la izquierda
verdad tomar un cambio en x igual a
menos 1 que digamos más o menos ahí y
entonces tendríamos un cambio en y de
menos 2 verdad tendríamos menos 2
entonces donde encontramos este 2 en
nuestra ecuación pues justamente
corresponde a esta constante verdad esta
constante es justamente la pendiente
de hecho en general vamos a tener que la
segunda constante es nuestra ordenada al
origen verdad porque si hacemos x igual
a 0 no importa porque este multiplicado
solo nos va a dar este valor y
justamente corresponde a la altura de en
donde intersecta al eje verdad entonces
esta segunda constante siempre va a ser
la ordenada al origen y la primera
constante siempre va a ser la pendiente
verdad y es algo muy fácil de pensar si
por ejemplo no tomamos x sino x + 1 que
sería tomar una un incremento en x
verdad entonces este 2 al multiplicar al
1 nos va a dar otros 12 extra verdad que
va a corresponder al aumento en ye muy
bien entonces ya tenemos bien trabajado
de esta forma
que de hecho para mí particularmente me
parece que es la forma más fácil de
entender verdad vamos a ver cómo es esto
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo digamos que
tenemos ya igual al menos x más 2
entonces quedamos que esta segunda
constante siempre va a ser la ordenada
al origen entonces simplemente colocamos
este punto así de rápido y tenemos una
constante aquí la constante en realidad
es menos 1 verdad nuestra pendiente es
menos 1 quiere decir que si nos movemos
uno a la derecha vamos a tener uno hacia
abajo uno hacia abajo si nos movemos dos
a la derecha vamos a tener dos hacia
abajo entonces con estos puntos ya
podríamos fácilmente graficar nuestra
línea vamos a hacer algo así
aunque allí tenemos parte de nuestra
línea de hecho podríamos ponerlo en la
otra dirección verdad pero con eso nos
basta por ahora ya pudimos así de fácil
dibujar nuestra recta realmente es muy
fácil trabajar con la forma de pendiente
ordenada al origen porque este no se
dice inmediatamente quién es la
pendiente verdad la pendiente es igual a
menos 1 y que corresponde a esta
constante y la ordenada al origen la
ordenada al origen vamos a escribirlo la
ordenada al origen corresponde al punto
0 2 y eso ya estaba en esta parte de la
ecuación